hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford and here's our take
on the weekly events from America the UK
and around the world and this week we're
going to focus on the state of the union
address as the US economy recovers
President Obama bounces back and goes on
the offensive the shadow of crisis has
passed and the state of the union is
strong as his approvals ratings rise the
president exuded confidence and defiance
I have no more campaigns to run my only
agenda
I know cuz I won both
he says it's not a partisan occasion
President Obama's vision for United
States where the rich are taxed heavily
to help the less well-off a foreign
policy of diplomacy and building
coalitions and wiping out Islamic state
terror will be a lasting legacy such was
Barack Obama's penultimate State of the
Union address well as usual the Democrat
commentator Geoffrey Robinson is in New
York and the conservative commentator
Armstrong Williams is in Washington
gentlemen a bit like a debate i'm going
to give you just a few seconds to give
me your opening thoughts on this Jeffrey
you go first he set the agenda for 2016
laid the foundation for Hillary Clinton
he put the Republicans on the back foot
took the offensive and did it with great
swagger it was one of his better
speeches of all times I'm song you know
I agree that it's one of his better
speeches of all times I found the
interest in that he said that women
deserve that the Equal Pay is men there
was a report in The Washington Post
recently where women in the White House
makes for less money than the men and I
think President Obama needs to look at
his own house and also in state of the
union he claimed that Obamacare had
helped cut the deficit by I think he
said two thirds by slowing the rate of
healthcare spending growth that is
actually a false claim because Obamacare
has created a deficit time bomb that
will explode just as he is leaving
office now it is true that growth of
health care spending has fallen during
his presidency okay I'm strong will come
back to the health care issue I'm sure
joining us from Washington though is a
former democrat representative and
former two-time Democrat presidential
candidate Dennis Kucinich Dennis thanks
for being part of our program today what
did you make it a speech well it would
have been a great speech six years ago
as an inaugural it would have been great
to issue a mandate for the Democratic
Party to carry forth those policies when
a democratic party indeed had control of
both the House the Senate and the
presidency unfortunately when the
president was in a position
something about those issues he did not
do that and as a result since 2008
ninety-five percent of the income gains
in the economy have gone to the top 1%
the Democratic Party is in tatters and
what we saw yesterday was rhetoric to
try to set the stage for 2016 but it's
like giving people a picture of a carrot
when Wall Street got the whole carrot
patch let's bring in Jeffrey and
Armstrong if we can Jeffrey Denny seems
to be saying to us that the president
might have saved the country and put it
on the right path but he's messed up if
not ruined the Democrat Party no I'm not
quite an agreement with my friend Dennis
no no you have to remember that the
people who stopped him from doing
anything once he lost the house with the
Republicans they vetoed everything they
were against absolutely everything he
wanted to do so the Republicans haven't
been playing ball and the Republicans I
think are largely responsible for all
the damage that's been done in the past
six years to the programs he wanted to
get through the fact is he's very
defiant now is nothing to lose and he's
going to push it down the throat to the
Republicans one of the things that
really interested me last night in
watching both sides of the house unlike
previous years when the Republicans sat
on their hands for everything this time
there were a few people not many but
still a few Republicans who actually
applauded some of the things like equal
pay for equal of for women there is that
there are fissures in the Republican
Party John Boehner is not leading a
united house there's the the the crazies
the lunatic fringe in the Tea Party but
there are also some moderate Republicans
who may very well start pushing an
agenda that is a lot more palatable to
the American people than the usual
Republican do nothing veto the president
agenda Armstrong do you think as Dennis
says that if he pushed this middle of
the road middle-class economics agenda a
few years ago he DeGraw he would have
got some across the aisle agreement you
know I have to tell you much respect for
former congressman Kucinich
for being honest and really showing
integrity on today's broadcast because
listen he's a former House member he
dealt with these issues he knows the
games that are played and what he said
really resonated with me on this level
because he's right about this in reality
not only are the nation's biggest banks
are bigger than ever I thanks in no
spark to Obama's dodd-frank laws but
consumers have seen almost none of the
financial relief a pump that was a
promise and during the peak of the
crisis Obama actually use middle-class
homeowners to prop up Wall Street banks
Sokka signatures right and while the
hell knows all these multi-billion
dollar settlements with JP market and
bank of america for the actions before
and during the financial crisis the
dollar amounts of these settlements have
actually green greatly inflated that
look uh obviously um I could resonate
with the president speech because it
permitted people really doesn't matter
who's in the White House is not going to
really impact their economy but for the
middle class the middle class is going
to shrink the poor will get poor and
ksenia is absolutely right if the
president really wanted to make real
change you should have done this early
on you know and I look and I am someone
who's conservative but I think sometimes
as consented just pointing out you need
to point out the truth and you need to
tell it like it is and instead of paring
back government programs like the FDIC
that a lot of these big banks to only
get bigger he's chosen to try and
micromanage those banks with bucket with
government bureaucrats and it is only a
matter of time guys and and consented
can understand this before the banks
paid millions to these outsmart their
bureaucrats overseas managed to get a
tax bill again yes all they're looking
for is more of a tax bill out on the
backs of the middle class and the poor
that the president advocates that he's
trying to help okay it's less absolutely
correct let's just drill down into one
of the campaign's let me bring you
Dennis Kucinich against on this one of
the talking points he raised one of the
issues he raised was community college
he said let's try and get everyone's
post-16 education up a whole notch and
free community college would be
President Obama's way of doing that is
there any
you can get cross-party support for that
well i think democrats would certainly
support that however you have to look at
where the money is going in the budget
you know it's all well and good to
advocate free college I'm for it
actually I'm for free college at the
university level in every public college
in the country however where's the money
going to come from the president has
throughout his term prosecuted wars that
will end up costing trillions of dollars
and he is still reaching forward with a
foreign policy that's going to be very
expensive with America are continuing to
be the policeman of the world so I think
that well we can go through a wish list
of things that we that Democrats may
agree on you know the president's
pushing these things out there i think
the gain and try to gain an advantage
for democrats in a 2016 election but why
should you know I'm a Democrat but I say
why should people want to support
Democrats if they didn't deliver when
they the one they were in power sure
that's what it goes back to okay but
hang on I'm not on that foreign
adventures bill and you say is now going
to cost the american nation for the
foreseeable future what would you cut
back what would you trim of that part of
the budget in order to do some of these
domestic things I I don't think there's
any purpose in this day and age in
America having dozens if not over a
hundred bases around the world what's
that about we you know we we have this
old thinking we need to be strong as a
nation we need to have a strong defense
we need to be able to protect our
country but how do we protect our
country by having America in a sense be
you know establishing an Imperium I just
I'm very concerned that we are losing
our capacity to be able to take care of
things here at home by getting our nose
and everybody else's business trying to
be the policeman of the world trying to
pretend that that our security as a
nation
it is not in making sure that wages
rides for everyone and everyone can have
a roof over the head and every connect
one can have health care and education
but that we can be the biggest and
toughest guy in a black I don't know
about that I think the problem is no
longer the threats from nation states
from non-state actors we need to deal
with them in a more efficient effective
way and we haven't done that and at this
point what we see coming out of the
White House is is really too late not
enough and where we need the United
States to be present on a world stage to
assert itself diplomatically we remove
ourselves and instead we substitute
military force for a diploma to show but
that doesn't work let me flip it back to
Jeffrey if I may but on the foreign
policy issue Jeffrey if you just address
that if you could I mean if it is going
to be Hillary Clinton she at least
should know what she's talking about if
she has some fresh thoughts on where
America's status in the world is Hillary
is is to the right of Barack Obama when
it comes to foreign policy and the
millet use of the military she's much
more hawkish than then he is now Dennis
you've just heard why 48 terms in
Congress dennis was a big star I mean
he's wonderful and and you can argue
with many of the things he says but he
he's one of the few people on either
side who actually supports what he says
with some fact and and I'm a big Dennis
fan the fact is however it's not too
little too late it's better late than
never he is laying the groundwork for
2016 he is thinking long term and there
will be a solution to Isis because even
the Republicans will get behind the
President on this and we will figure out
a way to wipe them out and we have the
military strength to do that and we have
the allies who want to do that I I don't
think the the conclusion is anything but
already drawn that Isis will disappear
there will be somebody else they'll be
Boko Haram there'll be somebody else it
takes this place but that's the nature
of politics in certain parts of the
world that's for Community College it's
very simple how to pay for it you take
the bush tax cuts for the rich and you
roll them back and you get the Koch
brothers to pay their fair share and
that will go a long way and
helping educate the American
schoolchildren who by the way are
victims of the Republican plan to do
away with the part Department of
Education I mean the insanity on the
side of the Republicans is is
mind-boggling okay Jeffrey let me just
stay in the security groove if i can
with a another question for dennis here
dennis kucinich the president referred
to cyber crime we've all gotten our
minds over the Christmas time we had the
whole Sony Pictures going on that is a
real issue for most nations around the
world and perhaps particularly America
isn't it certainly we want our
government our businesses and ourselves
to be free from hackers I would submit
to you that the greater threat in the
United States is the National Security
Agency which has the ability to reach
very deeply into people's private lives
to gather data to store it from
computers from telephones and text
messages and and essentially has created
the shift in our democracy away from a
constitutionally based principle of the
Fourth Amendment which relates to being
free from unreasonable search and
seizure yes we do need protection from
hackers every business works to achieve
that the government has hundreds of
people are on staff who are very skilled
who work to achieve that hacking is
bound to be an ongoing problem that
needs to be addressed but I will tell
you that the greater problem in the
United States is the fact that our
Constitution has experienced a
destructive undermining in this
administration by the overreach of the
National Security Agency we don't need a
big brother looking over our shoulders
inquiring into every keystroke that the
American that any American may make and
I will and I will continue to challenge
the logic that came out of the so-called
Patriot Act which government officials
have used to continue to reach very
deeply into people's private lives
Dennis Kucinich thank you very much
indeed for being with us today thank you
well Andrew Mitchell is vice-chairman of
the influential british-american
parliamentary group and he joins us now
mr. Mitchell you no doubt heard the
state of the union address from the
president is it the case that when
America is doing well the rest of the
world can hope to follow in her wake
well we certainly have a huge interest
in America doing well and I think one of
the things that came out of the speech
was the fact that the American economy
and the British economy are on the up
there's been this very successful visit
by our prime minister to America last
week and on the economy there's no doubt
at all that we are both beginning to
prosper and one of the things that
unites nearly all the political parties
in Britain is the enthusiasm for
developing the free trade agenda between
America and Europe so that's part of our
economic future and we very much hope
that that will get a great deal of
attention in due course across the
Atlantic that the main part of course of
the of the State of the Union speech
that we watch with care is the approach
by the American president to foreign
affairs these very big issues that
disfigure our world at the moment and
there was quite a lot in the speech
which will have lifted British hearts
but what he said about the fight against
Isis about what he said about Cuba what
he said about Guantanamo to where the
last British prisoner Chaka Amir was on
the agenda between President Obama and
David Cameron and where I believe the
president said that he would do what he
could to advance that agenda but in
terms of foreign policy and foreign
affairs we worry in Britain that some of
the focus has moved towards the Pacific
we obviously a very keen to ensure that
American leadership without which little
will be possible especially on the
Middle East and Syria and Iraq continues
to be an important feature on the
American political scene and
I was struck by what Dennis said about
the importance of the diplomatic effort
by America on resolving some of these
very difficult disputes let me go to
Armstrong Williams with the question the
president raised about minimum wage he
was saying come on let's sort it out
across the nation and the idea which is
a bit alien to people in the UK that
nobody gets paid for sick days now is
that something that is a relatively
simple fix Armstrong you know what
listen I don't know which America that
sometimes that we're speaking about
because lyssa most corporations and CEOs
that I know that when workers have
built-in sick days uh which could be two
to three weeks depending on how long
they have been with the company
obviously it may be a different
situation with the government workers
but in the private sector that the sick
leave issue is not an issue also when
you talk about the issue of minimum wage
and I can speak as a CEO often times the
minimum wage especially when you talk
about small businesses that have 10
unless employees a lot of these
companies are not doing as well as these
larger larger corporations are these
myths are corporations were really
benefiting from the economy and they are
still struggling and when you're talking
about raising minimum wage they have to
make a decision of whether they're going
to grow their business or add new
employees and sometimes what they do
they don't add employees and sometimes
they cut employees and also for a lot of
these businesses minimum wage is also
really make people realize that there
are a lot of people who cannot find jobs
so suddenly have degrees from Harbor Ivy
League schools I have heavy science and
master's degree and they're seeking
these jobs that pay ten and twelve
dollars an hour and what happens the
minimum wage job doesn't give a lot of
these kids the opportunity who don't
have the skills and who have not really
been in the workforce to take advantage
of it and what it what it allows if you
leave the minimum wage at a minimum it
allows them to come in and gain the
experience it's not always about the
money it's about gaining experience
networking building skills and building
relationships so you can move on and
the point about the economy it is true
there are a lot of us I can speak
personally we've had a tremendous year
in terms of our economy but I can tell
you a lot of small businesses who are
not doing well at all and there are a
lot of Americans who are not doing well
in this economy and it's right if you're
already doing well you have a system in
place and and you're running businesses
that not really depend on the government
a lot of government policies you're
going to do well but the problem is is
that a lot of people because of this
economy and because that is still
sluggish they're still suffering people
cannot find jobs they cannot find
opportunities and and while I embrace
much of what the president has said
there's still a class of people that
can't even relate to what he's saying
about the drastic improvement it's karma
in fact many of them think that he's
talking about some country they're
unaware of Geoffrey Robinson is does
that mean if Armstrong's right that
actually the conversation over the next
two years right through whatever pans
out with the presidential race is it
still the economy stupid is the number
one topic of conversation it's always
the economy but Armstrong is not right
so there's no if Armstrong is completely
totally absolutely and conclusively
wrong because all of the evidence points
to the fact that where there is minimum
wage on the state level for instance the
ten dollars in something I think 1010
and some some places up to 15 the
economy prospers people do better an
employment is not does not suffer it
increases I mean that all the evidence
absolutely proves Armstrong very very
wrong will this be an issue with the
Republicans raise the minimum wage it is
actually possible that they might I mean
one of the things we haven't discussed
is the ace in the hole that the
president has got in his hand and that's
the the pipeline and he has said
repeatedly that he would not he would
veto the pipeline until he's got the
evidence that it will not be dangerous
that it will work and and I think he's
holding it as a card to play for some of
these programs like minimum wage he puts
a whole package together and then says
the Republicans
the pipeline in there and I'll approve
it and they will go for it that kind of
infrastructure investment Andrew
Mitchell is that something you'd relate
to I'm a suppose we've got our
high-speed railway discussion going on
in the UK right now yes I mean a lot of
the the points that have been raised by
your two commentators are points that
resonate with Britain you know we have
the same debate here about the minimum
wage where the Conservative Party might
party has has been pretty strongly in
favor of possible of increasing it
because we're conscious that people have
suffered greatly from the recession that
we have been through but the main focus
in Britain when we listen to the
president give his State of the Union
the commentators today in Britain on
that speech have been on the
International Affairs and what American
leadership is going to do to combat the
awful crisis in Syria Iraq and more
widely in the Middle East and northern
Africa as well because American
leadership is something which we rely on
so strongly and as a faithful and good
partner of America on the on these
issues of world concern we look to
America for strong leadership strong
diplomatic and military leadership in
trying to address and resolve these very
very difficult issues could I just ask
you guys for a quick thought and this is
it's this about the very process of
politics I remember before he was
president obama mr. Obama campaigned
about the dysfunctionality of Washington
how the two-party system where everybody
had to disagree with everybody else
didn't actually serve the American
people very well as we are reaching the
twilight of his presidency do you think
he had a point Jeffrey absolutely he had
a point I mean he even said so last
night he said we can do better if we set
politics aside let me just say to
Andrews point he's absolutely right the
special relationship is vital to world
security it is vital to the economic
prosperity of England and the United
States I think it is alive and well and
I say long may it wave I'm strong on the
question of politics does Washington
serve the rest of America well
uh they served themselves well and while
the president has the right rhetoric
that no one could really disagree with
his action says something totally
different he's setting up the dynamics
for the fight on immigration he's
setting up dynamics for the fight on the
Keystone and other issues that he's
going to have to confront a
republican-controlled Congress because
it's the first time in his
administration that he's ever had a
state of the union where both parties
were dominated by Republicans and he
knows that he's going to make the
American people believe in his rhetoric
that he wants to work with him he wants
to cooperate but the problem is the
president was the Republicans to
cooperate with them he doesn't want to
meet them halfway and that's what that
is about and that and because John
Boehner as much is um he's criticized by
Jeffrey um I don't know any other
speaker that has reached across the
aisle anybody else in the party you've
reached out and try to work with this
president on a consistent basis to get
things done Jeffrey you can't see among
strong but he's shaking his head he's
almost crying he's weeping I mean up
we're saying he's a relationship reality
sure he should be because he should be
ashamed of some of the things that he
said today but i'ma leave that alone
because he's my brother and I respect
him and I'm just going to say what I'm
gonna say look that is nothing about
hogwash that the president talked about
in terms of leaving your interest Assad
and how people don't think about in your
constituency if you vote this way if
only that were true and he was a part of
the solution and he's not he's part of
the problem okay I'm strong Jeffrey
thank you let me give a final word here
to Andrew on this question of whether
these slightly messy political
democracies we have both sides of the
Atlantic do they serve the people well
just a few thoughts well we've seen of
course the breakdown after a very long
time of the two-party dominance in
government with the government that's in
power in Britain at the moment where we
have a coalition the first time in
peacetime we've had a coalition since
nineteen thirty-one and I think actually
the public like it more than the
politicians do the dominance in British
politics of the two major parties the
Conservative Party and the labour party
is at an all-time low with other parties
now occupying the politicals
base in quite considerable numbers and
if you look at some of the polling in
Britain I don't know what the result of
this election is going to be but there's
a powerful group of polling opinion
which suggests that the next government
could involve not to coalition partners
but three or more Andrew Mitchell
Geoffrey Robinson Armstrong Williams
thank you very much indeed and that's it
for this edition of the debate until
next time goodbye